[Musique]
tri pour en parler nous sommes avec jean
christophe lagarde président de l'udps
et y député de la 5e circonscription de
seine-saint-denis bonsoir jean
christophe lagarde merci d'être avec
nous à vos côtés joëlle mélin députée
européenne est reine qui est également
médecin généraliste qui n'exerce plus
haut mais vettel dit la dernière fois
mais on reste toujours médecin n'est ce
pas merci joëlle mélin d'être avec nous
également en direct sur rt france alors
le digital grimaçant c'est ainsi que
ursula von der leyen appel ce fameux
passeport numérique elle veut proposer
aux vingt-sept pour voyager notamment
cet été alors elle ne prononce pas c'est
important de le dire le mot de
passeports vaccinale mais personne n'est
dupe à ce que cette option semble
inéluctable un joëlle mélin il ya écouté
que les personnes qui peuvent justifier
reverte quels qu'ils soient négatifs
depuis moins de 48 heures que ceux qui
ont été vaccinées peuvent en justifier
ou ceux qui ont eu malheureusement eu la
maladie mais peuvent sans justifier
aussi puissent bénéficier d'un peu de
respiration ça me paraît tout à fait
normal
à partir de là dès l'instant que dans un
cadre qui s'inscrit très largement dans
l'europe nous puissions dire à tous ceux
qui sont dans ces situations là et tout
en gardant bien entendu on en reparle à
tout à l'heure les gestes barrière si ce
serait grave tous nos gestes barrières
que certains sont encore négatifs
bien entendu ils ont sur un document
médical il est leur propriété on en
reparlera la hausse du risque de
captation des données
moi je ne vois pas de difficulté à ce
que chacun ait son petit dossier médical
sur soi pour pouvoir bénéficier d'un peu
plus de liberté en attendant que tout le
monde soit vaccinée ou que l'on est
on a par là aussi tout à l'heure les
alternatives médicale en revanche le
terme de face au vide face maladie de
pas de porte sont totalement
inappropriés
alors jean christophe lagarde pour vous
on ne prononce pas le nom mais c'est
bien vous verse la con
ça rapproche passeport vaccinale
finalement que la france ne voulait pas
tellement et que d'ailleurs emmanuel
macron nous est toujours pas goûté je
veux et je me fiche absolument qu'on
appelle ça un passeport vaccinale un
carnet de vaccination j'en sais rien une
carte bleue verte aux violettes
je m'en fous je vous dis simplement nous
sommes les seuls à liquider le mois de
décembre un bandit évidemment que la
vaccination c'était la solution à
l'heure d'ailleurs d'autres y compris
des responsables politiques je pense à
madame le pen 0 la vaccination
attention nous avons dit la vaccination
c'est la seule solution est donc quand
des gens sont vaccinés il faut leur
permettre de ne pas se retrouver
enfermés dans leur vie sociale comme
nous le sommes tous depuis maintenant
plusieurs mois
c'est assez simple finalement à
comprendre bord il ya ce qui va être
décidé par les états étrangers quand
vous voulez voyager
personne y compris au sein de l'europe
ne va en paix interdire la grèce de
demander ou d'autoriser tous ceux qui
ont un passeport vaccinale de rentrer
dans leur pays
bon et vous imaginez donc un français
qui va se retrouver c'est là où je ne
comprends pas du tout le gouvernement
français qui va se retrouver autorisé à
aller en grèce parce qu'il aura été
vaccinées qu'il aura la certification de
vaccination appelez la comme vous voulez
je m'en fiche mais par contre il peut
pas aller dans sa salle de sport il peut
pas aller rendre à ses ancêtres pour un
de ses anciens dans un ehpad
il peut pas aller dans un restaurant
dans un bar c'est juste ridicule
moi je dis simplement que comme nous
sommes en train de vacciner on doit se
préparer à une possibilité pour tous
ceux qui ont été vaccinés de retrouver
une vie normale et on expliquera pas 20
25 ou 30 millions de français qui auront
été vaccinés qui doivent continuer à
vivre enfermé c'est aussi simple que ça
alors enfermé vis-à-vis de l'extérieur
quand ils veulent voyager ou enfermés
dans leur vie quotidienne quand ils
veulent aller au bar au restaurant
concert je termine en vous disant tout à
l'heure on entend des balles à mme
bachelot dire ah bah oui moi je m'occupe
pas forcément là en ce moment ce n'est
pas le moment très bien mais c'est
maintenant qu'on est en train de
vacciner les gens c'est au fur 1
mesure que la vaccination va s'élargir
puisque ce que je dis n'a de sens que si
elle est offerte à tous les français
c'est à dire à partir du mois d'avril du
mois de mai qu'il faut prévoir pour
faire des festivals cet été qu'il faut
avoir été vaccinée pour s'y retrouver si
tous les gens qui ont été vaccinés se
retrouve dans le festival il ya aucun
problème de santé
ils peuvent exister sinon elle va venir
pleurnicher dans quelques mois pour nous
expliquer que finalement ils avaient pas
prévu et comme toujours on a été en
retard sur les masques sur les tests
aujourd'hui sur la vaccination
on va même être en retard sur la grèce
sur l'italie sur le portugal quand il
s'agit d'un document qui vous permet de
montrer qui est en vacciner vous pouvez
revivre plus normalement en tout cas
certains critiquent cette idée du
passeport vaccinale pas ce genre 6 sur
les mots parce que emmanuel macron
justement on ne veut pas imposer l'idée
qu'on échange certificat de j'ai fait
mon vaccin
j'ai fait mon vexant et je peux donc
voyager il n'a pas envie en tout cas de
l'assumer écouter ce qu'on pense par
exemple florian philippot avant de
redonner la parole à joëlle mélin
l'allemagne annonce à son tour un
passeport sanitaires
le lendemain de la même annonce par
macron très clairement ce passeport de
discrimination était décidée par l'union
européenne on veut nous voler le débat
et la liberté de décider souverainement
joel la menace est un faux débat ça on
veut nous voler ce débat ça doit être un
débat français justement ce passeport
vaccinale c'est à dire j'ai fait mon
vaccin et voilà je peux voyager parce
que c'est quand même de cela qu'il
s'agit au fond je vais écouter
pardonnez moi mais c'est un faux débat
parce que même si vous avez le vaccin et
quand entendu que les vaccins que nous
avons actuellement à arn messager ou adn
message et non pas les caractéristiques
d'empêcher que vous vous retrouviez
qu'est la maladie
vous ne la développe réparé mais vous
pouvez toujours la transmettre c'est
donc une saillie vaccination et qu'il
redonne de la liberté pour que à côté on
garde tous les gestes barrière se confie
pas être très clair là dessus et le fait
d'avoir eu les vaccins actuels ne vous
exonère pas du tout de toute les autres
précautions par contre vous casser à
tout le moins au maximum de vos
possibilités
la chaîne de contamination
c'est ça que ça veut dire donc ça vous
autorise va avoir plus de liberté dans
pour retrouver la vie d'avant ça
n'empêche pas de continuer d'être dans
quelque chose de malgré tout de grandes
précautions
voilà pourquoi j'ai l'impression que les
gens qui parlent de tout ça non pas du
tout compris la problématique réelle qui
va et nous voyons très bien que si on
regarde de près c'est pas trois vagues
que nous avons eue c'est semble-t-il
semble-t-il trois épisodes différents
qui manifestement par toutes les
techniques qui ont été mises en place et
semi confinement les les couvre-feux les
confinements complet les festes marieur
c'est trois épidémies c'est plus de soi
même les deux dernières par contre enfin
à tous - celle de fès de cpt ils
s'imposent ils veulent et qui dans la
région marseillaise ne s'est pas levé
encore est le dernier qui est celle du
des variants anglais ou les autres qui
vont venir s'épuise petit à petit mais
il est vrai qu'on est loin loin loin du
compte qu'on a encore des inquiétudes à
se faire pour des raisons à peu près
automatique si vous voulez de
contamination
sauf que je note quand même que nous
sommes et c'est vrai dans une sorte de
stagnation de la maladie toutes causes
confondues et nous arrivons malgré tout
à maîtriser petit à petit il faut donc
que ceux qui peuvent reprendre une vie
normale le pas avec des grandes
précautions
je rappelle que ces vaccins ne sont pas
complètement
il faut avoir des effets des crocs
continuer de se protéger et dont deux
chez par les passeports vaccinale qui
ferait la panacée pour le coup ça ne
ferait pas du tout la vérité
scientifique et de là à dire que l'on
peut circuler sans faire attention ce
n'est pas encore là la vérité
scientifique alors je voudrais vous
faire réagir sur ce qu'on pense william
dab un épidémiologiste anciens direct
puis à laizy vous en prie jean
christophe lagarde bien sûr d'abord si
je peux me permettre ce que dit monsieur
philippot est plus que sujet à caution
c'est le même bonhomme qui nous
expliquait canton dernier que les
masques servait à rien ça va deux
minutes
peut-être qu'il faut qu'on se remette
sur des choses un peu plus sérieuses
deuxième chose je ne suis pas d'accord
avec l'idée que les vaccins aujourd'hui
sont des deux vaccins certes ils
protègent les gens et c'est démontrer
scientifiquement qui
sont vaccinés et quant à la transmission
contrairement à ce que vous dites
il n'est pas encore totalement démontrer
je le reconnais bien volontiers que sa
limite m'enfin docteur une moi je fais
partie des gens qui comme ils sont pas
docteur ils comprennent rien mais il y
il essaye de comprendre aux débats de
scientifiques et je vois juste une chose
c'est que le processus arn notamment il
est fait pour faire en sorte que quand
vous avez attrapé la maladie elle ne
puisse pas rentrer dans votre cellule
or un virus pour pouvoir se multiplient
il a besoin
entre pas dedans himeur donc votre
charge virale diminue chaque jour donc
vous êtes beaucoup moins contagieux
autrement et en tout état de cause
j'imagine que vous ne contesterait pas
la chose suivante c'est que si vous
mettez dans un restaurant dans une salle
de sport dans une salle de concert des
personnes vaccinées
aucune d'entre elles ne risquent rien
quand bien même une d'entre elles
pourraient un petit peu un petit peu
moins que les on est un petit peu
contaminés et donc ça permettrait de
rouvrir la vie sociale je ne dis pas
qu'il faut négliger ou refuser à ceux
qui refusent la vaccination de vivre il
faut qui concerne les gestes barrières
que vous évoquez vous avez raison il
faut qu'on achète et on l'a fait avec
trois semaines de retard par rapport à
l'allemagne
des médicaments antiviraux qui
permettent de lutter contre cette
maladie
mais il n'y a aucune raison d'empêcher
ceux qui sont vaccinées de reprendre une
vie normale et plus vite cette vie
normale reprendra dans la santé
psychologique pour la santé économique
et pour la santé sociale de notre pays
mieux ce sera voilà ce que je défends
comme idée et c'est pas le passeport
vaccinale le pass le carnet sanitaire et
quant à monsieur macron quand même il
faut arrêter de se du monde
excusez moi mais nous expliquer qui va
avoir une application antique au bide
plus c'est à dire avant il y avait que
si jamais j'ai rencontré quelqu'un de
vaccine de contaminer aujourd'hui on
pourra dire que j'ai été vacciné ou que
j'ai été détecté il ya pas longtemps
vous savez combien de français sur 70
millions qui sont actuellement connectés
sur le antico vic c'est à dire ce qu'ils
nous proposent 13 millions sur 70
millions c'est sérieux ça ça pose
effectivement la question en tout cas
des libertés publiques informatique
libertés individuelles je vous propose
justement d'écouté monsieur
dupont-aignan sur ce point emmanuel
macron s'est dévoilée il avance
insidieusement vers le passeport
vaccinale les français savent désormais
que voter macron en 2022
c'est voter pour le fichage généralisé
et la fin de nos libertés
trop c'est trop un joël ménard justement
jean christophe lagarde évoqué cette
appli qu'ovide beaucoup de français sont
réticents peut-être précisément à cause
de ce fichage généralisé des santé
demeure dans la de la santé et la femme
de liberté vous êtes d'accord avec ce
postulat écouter sur les français libres
de savoir s'ils veulent avoir une
application de plus sur leur téléphone
pas que je peux quand même dire si vous
voulez et qu' il y à une loi en france
qui depuis 2002 protège les dossiers des
patients et les patients son ovation
malade une future maladies potentielles
manade bien évidemment de chaque préfet
est propriétaire de son dossier
les 500 milles l'annoncent des cinq cent
mille dossiers de biologie qui ont été
hackés piratés est un vrai problème
les hôpitaux qui ont été bloqués sont
revenus en papier tout simplement parce
que ils ne peuvent plus les hôpitaux
sont bloqués alors moi ce que je crois
c'est que ces applications c'est bien
mais encore faudrait-il que les
indications issoire pop aurait consenti
par les personnes qui les utilisent et
en tout cas que ces données puis ne pas
être captée par qui que ce soit parce
que eiffage fait témoigner de du travail
que je fais actuellement parlement
européen à l'occasion de cette crise du
coc vide
l'union européenne dans le cadre des
données générales et la stratégie de la
protection des données mais surtout de
l'utilisation des données voudrait à
partir des données de santé faire une
énorme masse de données une énorme bang
des données vous pensez bien que les
gars femme qui ceux qui ont de la
consommation adversaires mais aussi les
assurances mais aussi ceux qui veulent
savoir où et le patrimoine
ceux qui veulent savoir l'état de santé
des gens sont tout à fait à l'affût de
ce genre de
comment dirais-je d'indications alors
qu'elle est la réticence je le comprends
parfaitement faut donc retrouver des
systèmes relativement simple la
numérisation l'intelligence artificielle
c'est bien les porteurs de progrès il
faut savoir la maîtriser et je ne suis
pas sûr qu'il faille ouvrir les vannes
des données à propos de la santé voilà
en tout cas ce que disait tout à l'heure
monsieur la gare de lille est tout à
fait impensable qu'on arrive à des
situations où le chevalier en tel
cafouillage à propos des décisions de
monsieur macron qui est évidemment un
temps de retard sur tout mais pas que et
très sincèrement que d'entendre encore
aujourd'hui il n'est pas question pour
l'instant de parler d'auto turf alors
que des tas d'entreprises l'effet des
start-up attendent les certifications
qui l'ont d'ailleurs même déjà dans
d'autres pays étrangers
c'est insupportable il voudrait jeter
les mots c'est pas comme si on dirait
que personne n'aurait pas tellement
intérêts à photoshop est quand même
assez extraordinaire cette affaire là
nous avons les moyens nous en sortir
nous avons les moyens maintenant de
déborder les études qui ont été lancés à
grands frais depuis maintenant quatorze
mois il est urgent pour trouvent les
auvergnats thibault lassalle pour que
ceux qui sont réticents
ce que touche qu'ils soient qu'ils
veulent ce qu'avec mais le cuit mais là
on en reprend la paix tout à l'heure il
ya un authentique problèmes de
fabrication mais c'est un problème où
les états sont un petit peu quoi est
fait par la chaîne de fabrication des
labos très jean christophe lagarde le
mot de la fin vous demandons et vous est
certainement répondre à votre
interlocutrice
faut-il finalement l'imposé se passe
vaccinale comme vous dites on l'appelle
comme on veut le pass sanitaires on sait
que la région ne me vient est en train
de le tester d'autres pays européens s'y
prépare on l'a dit et ce qu'il faut
l'imposer également en france puisqu'on
le sait vous êtes pour on l'avait dit
juste avant de vous répondre je vais
quand même vous dire que monsieur
dupont-aignan monsieur qui dit faux on
m'a même le pen passent leur temps à
suivre l'opinion plutôt qu'elle a dirigé
pour moi un dirigeant ce à dire est que
l'opinion
il ya quelques mois et que vous
expliquez que le vaccin c'est écrire il
condamne on était plus que macha etc
puis aujourd'hui finalement il souffre
au cerveau à signer mais lisa il faut
pas de passes sanitaires ben c'est pas
comme ça qu'on gouverne un peuple c'est
pas comme ça qu'on gouverne un pays on
doit d'abord et avant tout se projeter
vers l'avenir
évidemment que personne et vous les
dirigent vous donne rendez vous dans
trois mois
expliquera quand la vaccination sera
ouverte à tout le monde que tous les
vacciner doivent vivre enfermé c'est
aussi simple que ça premier élément
deuxième élément ce passeport se passe
cette carte maximale appelez ça comme
vous voulez il est nécessaire parce que
c'est une évidence scientifique d'être
vaccinés ou de ne pas l'être
ça n'est pas la même chose ça ne vous
expose pas aux mêmes risques et ça
n'expose pas les autres aux mêmes
risques et donc il faut s'y préparer
maintenant c'est que pendant qu'on est
en train de vacciner les gens qui vont
se poser la question c'est pas après
c'est pour ça que nous à l'unisson la
posait dès le mois de décembre dernier
en 10 ans préparons-nous maintenant
parce que au printemps à l'été on va
pouvoir grâce à la vaccination permettre
une vie sociale plus normal dernier
élément
moi je ne suis pas pour qu'on impose je
suis pour la responsabilité individuelle
d'abord il ya des gens qui disent ok je
fais confiance dans la science et je
veux me faire vacciner
aucune raison de continuer les laisser
enfermer il ya des gens qui disent je
n'ai pas confiance et dans ces cas là
ces gens là c'est respectable doivent
continuer à s'abstenir d'un certain
nombre d'activités à respecter des
gestes barrières etc
et il ya un troisième d'une troisième
catégorie de population
ceux qui ne peuvent pas être vaccinés
même s'ils le veulent parce que par
exemple il présente des risques
allergiques gelé vu dans le centre de
vaccination de ben ali de drancy il ya
des gens que les médecins refusent la
vaccination peu nombreux mais ils le
font pour les préserver très bien on
peut pas les laisser tomber
ils doivent évidemment aussi continuer à
respecter des gestes barrières et nous
devons avoir les médicaments nécessaires
pour les soigner au cas où ils attrapent
la maladie ce sont les médicaments qui
ont servi expérimenta mentalement à ce
fameux monsieur trucks que l'allemagne a
acheté à hauteur de 200 mille doses il
ya déjà un mois et que nous venons à
peine de changer ya cent mille doses un
la même population
il ya quelques jours j'en ai marre en
vérité j'en ai marre que nous soyons en
retard sur plus sur les masques les
tests les vaccins le passeport vaccinale
et même les médicaments non non non il
faut arrêter de nous prendre pour des
enfants nous permettent de raisonner en
adulte et raisonnables responsables et
surmonter cette fuite
merci jean christophe lagarde merci
également à joëlle mélin d'avoir été
avec
en direct sur arte france